ysabelle lacamp tu as eu un destin la
fois romanesque et littéraire pour
malaise parce que ton père a rencontré
jolly coréenne d'appstore ordinaire
c'était max olivier lacan qui a vu le
renaudot d'ailleurs pour les frais de la
colère en passant de 9 la rencontre et
unique orange avait été tuée d'une seule
fille de koren en france parce que c'est
encore très rares cinq ans maintenant
withera parce que maman elle et a donc
cédé lundi depuis 30 ans a accepté de
désole la sentait absolument pas et de
suivre mais avec contre tous les
français quelle haine
elle est encore une pionnière en fait on
nous a beaucoup
séoul est avec les jeux olympiques et
j'ai lu un papier toi dans l justement
où tu parles des étés femme coréenne
jeudi par exemple quel 120 minutes pour
choisir leurs maris corpus bourg et
qu'en même temps il faut complètement
place bourré de toute façon elle bosse
avec pas mal de vent
c'est le mariage arrangé encore
complètement domicile seraient visés
tout à l'heure c'est que comme qui doit
obéir à tes parents donc tu dois
accepter le choix du nom de mary quant à
bosse et qui n'a rien à dire je sais
c'est aussi la même chose pour les
versions sauf que les garçons s'en tire
à bon compte parce qu'il connaît pas de
problème on va avoir quelques petites
concubinage mais fagots mais la femme
est restée là disons à la maison tu dis
aussi que la pilule est en vente libre
mais que sa fille se marie elle doit
être vierge et qu'on refait les emails
on fait comment pour refaire un iman
avant le mariage
écoute je sais pas je sais pas si ce
patient non et je pense qu'on va prendre
une grande aiguille et puis on veut
coûts dans tous avancer je suis dit
quand on est un business man encore et
on peut commander un café la fille qui
vous l'amène à l'est les caresses sont
compris dans le prix du café 30 entités
arriver à temps plein
bon c'est vrai ça un salut maintenant
j'ai tout suivi environ dans les cafés
arrive on comprend complètement et bien
jilcot fait éventuellement de cette
cicatrice de cette cicatrice est compris
dans le prix c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
déjà quoi je pensais alors on parlait
donc de ta carrière littéraire
tu as fait le baiser du dragon kahn a
vendu combien maximum avant tout sa
création mais j'en ai compté pas mal on
sait une superbe chance prendrait
autrement
depuis sa sortie en poche du marché et
le deuxième s'appelle la fille du ciel
scène je crois que cela finisse par
l'histoire en la même héroïne que dans
le baiser du dragon
c'est une femme pas du tout sourire
plutôt libérés pour l'époque puisque
l'époque pour ça se passe en chine 60
ans avant ma mort
et puis bon c'est c'est une fille
complètement anarchique complètement
morcelé en plein du royaume et surtout
menacée au nord par l'invasion des
ancêtres de gengis khan de c
une redoutable quittant de mongols et
donc ils se sont installés à l'intérieur
de la grande muraille dans pékin et qui
me lasse de contenir toute la chine
et je trouvais super que la fille du
ciel donc le chou mais finalement tout
en essayant de ceux de se libérer de la
condition forme parce que parce qu'elle
est une femme active ou avant la lettre
l envie de participer au destin de son
pays
eh bien elle va elle va devenir un petit
peu le symbole de cette résistance
chinois tu sais que le palace a ré
ouvert avec une fête dédiée aux péchés
capitaux et tu sais ce pc les péchés
capitaux c'est la source de tous les
autres péchés en fait par richard une
interview confession
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je crois qu'on est tous sur bin oui je
pense qu'elle a connu ouais moi j'essaye
de tempérer l'avarice alors qu'est ce
que tu as fait de l'argent que tu as
rapporté des dragons tu l'a gardé chez
toi sous-tend matelas où je l'investis
oculaire non j'ai pas tout j'ai pas tué
d'abord les droits d'auteur qui les
touchent
- non après voilà c'est tout frais j'ai
le temps wire donc j'ai le temps de me
poser la question ouais
et puis pour moi le fait qu'on sait pas
il incita moyens c'est sûr c'est pas une
fin c'est un moment dans ma rue en masse
pour sa vie il a rejeté l'idée de
l'argent je crois que ça va allez savoir
dimanche je ne pose pas la question
la luxure là tu peux pas fait une
réponse laconique sur l'adduction non on
l'a dit souvent
dans son livre des passages qu'ils sont
sérieux ruine complètement ne sais pas
si je suis comme on dit une fille
luxuriante alors si c'est pas mal je
sais pas je préfère exposer ma luxure
dans l'écriture houston en plus marrant
et dans la vie tu en mets tout cas
public
je crois que suis très pudique et bon je
croise dans la rue on me dit souvent si
d'un côté toujours un peu de provocation
directe aux visites dragon tally voici
un site assez cool malgré tic
il était paillard en chine rappelait
ainsi qu'en moi je pense que tu as
provocation exhibition et la provocation
plus de moi je suis plus fort est
question pizza sac je pense que je ne me
cachais derrière nous
oui pourquoi pas en droit je suis allé
me léger la jeune âge à lui mais je la
vois là restera des fois ouais mais pas
seulement
sifflé dérange pas bon c'est ça la
luxure à la maison tu es pudique mais je
sais la joie balade madouni son balcon
avants dacquois n'ont jamais il ya quand
même où l'on dit est ce que tu as envie
les autres les scouts en vie les gens
comme ça quand tu étais grande carrière
littéraire qui est ce la personne qui va
voir le prix goncourt cette année moi je
suis contente oui abondé pas envieux non
je pense en tout cas c'est vraiment un
défaut de jeu je n'aime pas chez les
autres puissent pas juste pour les
gourmandes
je suis très gourmande sur tous les
péchés alors je vais complètement la
colère en colère en colère rentrée
contre moi moi je veux aller à contre
les gens rarement mois s'est un peu
loupé d'un je patiente et insultes dans
la rue on dit salignacois se tenir par
exemple non je rigole
derrière sa faune et sa flore et
équitable et d'y acheter ben moi je dis
si entre le liban et la paresse
moi je suis ici par ici mais je crois je
crois qu'on y fera que si j'étais dans
les choix moins 400 vaches pour être
préparé cela pour personne non mais je
suis aussi assis consciencieuse mechri
quand tu as une passion peut pas parler
celui d'une bonne dose de paraissait bon
voilà c'est la première télé que tu fais
mais tu vas faire là c'est pas l'argent
de raconter son livre comme ça tout le
monde pendant un mois elle défie ce sera
la raconter à chaque fois de façon
différente
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater levine
a l'habitude
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus